Hank: Good morning, John.
Since 1980, the cost of college in the US
has more than tripled, rising faster even
than the cost of medical care.
Around 70% of students in the US will graduate
with some amount of debt, and the average
amount for those students is $29,000, that's
$312 a month for ten years of student loan
payments.
Now, there are some ways in which you can
pay less, and if you're interested in those,
I put a link in the description, but it's
an undeniable fact that the costs of education
in America have increased greatly and that
student loan debt is becoming a burden, so
what are colleges spending that extra money
on?
Well, it's complicated.
Let's start with the fact that since 2008,
colleges have actually been spending less
money per student, but students have been
spending more money per student.
How's that possible?
Well, you might remember than in 2008, there
was something of a financial crisis.
State budget shrank, and so did some institutional
endowments, meaning that students paid more
and got less.
That trend actually stretches back even a
bit farther, with the top amount being paid
per student by states happening in 2001.
But of course, these costs have been increasing
since way before 2001, and colleges are spending
way more money than they used to, so what
do schools spend their money on?
Well, the first thing you think of is academic
instruction, and that is still the biggest
category of spending.
College professors are expensive, and in some
cases, you're asking them to come teach when
they could be working in the private sector
for pharmaceutical companies or investment
banks and making millions of dollars a year,
and you want those really highly qualified
amazing professors teaching and so yeah, sometimes
they get paid a lot.
The average amount of money a college professor
makes is around $150,000, but some professors
make upwards of a half a million dollars a
year.
But during the last 10 or 15 years, during
which the college costs literally doubled,
the cost of instruction basically kept pace
with inflation.
Part of the way schools have done that is
by now hiring on as many tenure track professors
and having a ton of like, part-time and grad
student and adjunct professors who do not
get paid very well at all.
So the cost of instruction overall is definitely
not where this big bump came from.
The costs that have definitely increased a
lot are in a jumble of different categories
that different institutions track differently
and so are very difficult to tease out apart
from each other, but there has been some really
great and careful research done on this stuff,
so here are the increases in a few categories.
Operations and grounds-keeping, room and board,
general administration, academic support,
and a nebulous thing which has increased more
than any other category among four year bachelor's
degree programs, "student services", which
includes everything from concerts to intramural
sports to marketing to tutors.
It appears that what's driving this is, in
a word, sales.
Colleges are acting more like businesses and
treating students more like customers.
Schools compete with each other, and in a
world where the costs are really high anyway,
it starts to look like a little fuzzy when
a student's deciding between $310 payments
for ten years and $340 payments.
It's only $30 a month, and if one school has
really nice dorms, a well supported tutoring
program, nice athletic fields, a super dope
climbing wall, a celebrity level professor,
cushy mattresses, and local, organic produce
and cafeteria salad bar,, then both the parents,
who are probably footing a big hunk of the
bill, and prospective students are likely
to choose the more expensive option.
Some of those things are worthwhile, others
don't have much use beyond, like, looking
pretty cool on prospective student weekend.
Building and running a 30,000 person institution
that has facilities that outpace the quite
nice country club is expensive.
Over the last 10 years, non-academic employees
have been hired 50% faster than academic employees
at colleges and universities, and top-level
administrators who are responsible for increasing
that enrollment and revenue so that there's
money for everybody to spend, their pay raises
have been more than double that of academic
employees.
The average school now has about one non-academic
employee for every 10 students.
There are some private schools where that
ratio is more like 1 to 3.
Now, the absolutely nutso thing about all
of this is that it still works, because even
at these juicily inflated prices, college
is still a good deal.
Money spent on a Bachelor's, Associate's,
or Professional degree yields a higher return
than the stock market, even in dropping out
of college after 18 months has a higher yield
than the stock market, though not as high
as graduating, so in a way, colleges are just
working their way up to costing as much as
the value they provide.
But I think that we can all safely agree that
college should not be about maximizing revenue,
especially for state schools.
The question isn't really whether college
is a good deal, it's whether college could
be a better deal.
It seems a little like the increase in spending
is kind of a natural outgrowth of a capitalist
society and people making decisions that benefit
them, at least in the short term, but it's
worth asking if treating America's students
like customers is, in the end, going to be
a disservice to everyone.
Maybe we shouldn't be selling students an
experience.
Maybe we should be providing them with as
much enrichment and, dare I say it, education
as possible.
Because while it is important that college
is a sound monetary investment, it is also
important, possibly more important, that students
get through our higher education system knowing
more about the world and about themselves,
and I don't think that that has to be a monetary
thing, and I definitely don't think it needs
to cost $40,000 a year.
I don't know, maybe I'm crazy.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.